one thing you'll you'll realize meeting
kevin is like he's like the most humble
and nice person like you've ever met you
know
um but then that that is until like he
starts getting like a few pints in him
yeah i'm like i can always like you can
always track how drunk kevin and kevin
is by how much more australian he is so
at the beginning of the line at the
beginning of the night you're like you
might not even know that he's australian
yeah like he's like way people like
kevin is either extremely professional
or extremely unprofessional
there's no
[Laughter]
yeah
oh that's flip okay
because i guess i remember like yeah
because you were saying like i
definitely experienced that this weekend
right because you know obviously like
during the convention you know we'd go
out and have a couple of drinks and all
that kind of stuff right and it's like
uh you know that that uh
that friday night where uh we're out you
know drinking and uh we got that burger
king at like two in the morning yeah and
bringing that up and you want that to be
committed to youtube yeah
because like you know god was saying
like you know you know kevin is drunk
because he just gets like exponentially
australian right and i think that burger
king knight was the most aussie i've
ever heard kevin i was so bitter about
that book it [ __ ] sucked it was so
[ __ ]
so to explain it's like it's like 2 30
in the morning obviously everyone's like
drunk and you know everyone's starting
to get the a little bit hungry right
yeah so there's a burger king there and
kevin comes out with like a bag full of
what he thinks is like
just a light snack right
when he pulls out of the bag
it's like the fattest
double whopper that i've ever seen in my
life
he pulls it out of the bag and he's like
in the most australian way he's like
what the [ __ ] is this
and he's like oh [ __ ] it i've already
bought it it's whatever so just like
this just like goes back to like the
[ __ ] izakaya thing where i ordered
too much can i just [ __ ] hit the
button yeah just hit the button oh my
god
and then kevin was like pretty hungry
you know we we we started drinking
before but kevin was like we were
[ __ ] tired yeah we we were hungry but
we also like just a little bit tipsy and
kevin thinks
kevin thinks you know what's a good idea
if i order one of everything on the menu
it's a four-page menu
it's four pages of menu for just the
chicken
it was like four pages of menu for like
it was like an onslaught it did not stop
yeah i've never had to like because
there's a it's a [ __ ] all you can eat
like you can just do it but yeah at the
same time i was like yeah we had like i
was like i had to talk to the [ __ ]
staff member like can you stop can you
can you stop
food that you have not physically yet
stop it
because it was like there was like 15
different livers and i'm like how do you
even find this many livers i'm just i'm
done you're going to assault this shield
so like
we learned that we if we go to an
izakaya and there's a tablet there we
can order never never give it together
because he's just like oh what does
everyone want and everyone's just like
oh just just whatever and kevin takes
that too literally as everything
well
because you know i think it's just
because like you know i haven't been
back home to australia in a while all
right and like you know i have a couple
of maids in australia who are like very
very awkward but like you know kevin is
like next level strangling especially
when he's drunk so he was like
yeah so like you know going back it's
like he like unwraps the double offer
right because he's like he's already has
it in his hand he takes like three bites
out of it and he just goes this [ __ ]
this is so [ __ ]
i don't think i remember that
it was so dry it was like so dry it was
so dry and it was so heavy yeah it was
like oh i [ __ ] up okay
i [ __ ] because like in australia we
don't have burger king we have angry
jacks hungry right yeah yeah so it's
like you know if burger king was like
better it's good it's funny yeah like
hungry jax is like i would argue way way
better than yeah but like but not by
much
not by much to be fit sorry no no no i
don't know if i'm crazy but i swear
burger king don't they like drench it in
like sauce
so [ __ ] dry
like the burger is like the most like
skeleton-esque burger yeah like
extremely anemic yeah i i had the
snapped the patty in half yeah i had the
chicken like uh like there was like a
long chicken burger type of thing and uh
and it was like it was so it was like
freeze-dried it was so [ __ ] dry i was
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bad
tactical yeah that will hopefully not
make it yeah but it's just so hilarious
just kevin raging at a double wobble at
2 30 in the morning i've got a good
friend back home i remember because i
took him to this like really like
there's this ankara bakery thing on it's
called street in um
yeah there's a place there's a there's
an ankara bakery on beaufort street in
mount lawley
i remember because he
took he said the same thing he tried to
throw it out and he and it exploded all
over his car
so this egg just [ __ ] went all over
his body
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but there is like yeah there's food
rage there's there's a lot of
approaching so
back to your music
it's just the process yeah yeah bit
inspired by drivers have a [ __ ] [ __ ]
burger and go write some [ __ ] angry
music
what do you call like a track and shield
here just like dry chicken salad
i started going like more like psycho
with the naming convention
i'm waiting for double whopper at 2am
the names only if you're like her
soundtracks right they're gonna hear
about the show right you could just make
no i mean if you're doing like an op d
they do have the opening yeah
yeah yeah
they use these tracks try chicken
sandwich like kevin right
[Laughter]
no because i did uh i didn't notice uh
in some of your tracks in shield hero
like i think the first shield there well
there were like some weird names in here
actually i'm gonna get it out now
because they were like they were like
some some of like the usual suspect
names of you know like generic anime
music names and then there was just
so so you go through this soundtrack
list and most of them are like you know
normal you know you have a track that's
called the rising of the shield hero of
course the titular title of course you
know you have like some you know isekai
type lists type track called like game
start and stuff like that and then you
go down to like near the bottom and then
there's a track called like spirit bomb
i'm like huh that that was that like a
cheap dragon ball z reference probably
is it's kevin okay we can we can we can
get away with that we can get away with
that and then then you're just like boom
boom boom
like kevin are you kind of running out
of names are you gonna hand it even
further and then you just there's a
track just called noms
[Laughter]
listen to the track and i'm just like
this this name has nothing to do with
the track at all and then you go next
it's like matty boy
boy
who's maddie boy who's maddie boy i want
to know
i can't explain the noms i'm out
my head
[Music]
with um frankie and uh
yeah yeah yeah the one that like got
certainly hacked by north korea yeah
yeah no no because like when when they
finally like shoot down kim jong-un in
the movie yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] franco's character just goes
and like fires a tank bullet into the
helicopter and that's the reference
what's that got to do with shield hero
[ __ ] nothing
is it even like a boomy track it's
it was 25 or 26 episodes so that that
required so basically
as um as i'm sure you all know but just
for chiropractic and all that sort of
thing yeah there's normally cause so one
core two courses yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like a season kind of oh so one core is
12 or 13 episodes
like 24 20. okay
so something along that length and so uh
for example ben bess is well then this
season one of course is uh like 13
episodes so it's one chord right right
shield hero had 26 episodes
yeah so normally for two cores you kind
of you don't double the music but you
probably like 1.5 times it right so um
for men best um the um
the this uh the season one i think the
soundtrack comes in at one hour and 52
minutes something like that right and i
think it's about
i think that was actually about 50
something tracks or like maybe 40
mid-40s
but then shield hero yeah it was about
60 62 tracks and it's about two hours
and 50 minutes of music and is that like
left up to you do you decide how many
tracks you're making
like hey we need 62 tracks make them all
sound good it's actually pretty specific
so what basically happens is when you
get commissioned to write anime music
you get a just basically a massive excel
sheet called the called the music order
yeah so when you're the music order it's
basically yeah just like you'll have
like m1 like music one and then it'll
say like main theme and then m2 will be
like main theme happy version
like m3 would be main theme dark version
or something yeah right right four main
theme hero version or something like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
quite generic sort of like descriptions
and they might have some explanation or
they might have some you know some
visual images and stuff like that so you
actually get a lot of freedom which i
really really like yeah so if you think
about how like because they'll they'll
have all that sort of thing in there
maybe once you get to like m20 would be
like battle one speed battle or like
battle two
like seriously
seriously sometimes i mean we can get
very specific as well but like it'll
start from that sort of like slightly
more abstract sort of approach which is
actually really really cool because that
way you you actually do have a lot of
kind of
like i said freedom to actually just
trying to explore different ideas like
like you get the freedom to call attract
norms
the track name doesn't really matter
though right because because we when
you're writing it um this has changed
like my process on this has changed like
a little bit since shield here in italy
so i probably wouldn't do that again but
yeah yeah
it was that was a process
hey you know
eventually
well um so um
when you're writing uh what what i like
to do is try and
match a lot of like sort of the textual
stuff i was talking about earlier yeah i
love trying to match texture to the
actual visual uh sort of um palette if
you will
um best way like one of the most sort of
like sort of basic examples of classic
examples i can give is uh inmate and
abyss obviously like it's quite a small
amount of like kind of kid characters
going into like huge like cavernous
abyss yeah instead of exploring also you
see in the visuals it's not there's
normally a lot of wide shots where you
just see kind of the the sport yeah yeah
yeah yeah it just goes like super fast
and so like the idea of trying to
actually depict that visual sort of
stimuli yeah music is is quite appealing
to me it's sort of um yeah almost like a
i it's called like word painting uh
which is basically like let's say you
have lyrics and say i'm going to rise up
and then the melody goes i am going to
rise up it's like it's like literally
rising with them
rising with the shield right here
actually because in the main theme it
like the the violence that part of the
star does actually rise up and like
right again it's like okay it sounds so
basic but it is good fun yeah
a lot a lot of the like chord stuff and
main abyss also like saw that descension
so you hear a lot of like
normally it's going it's still only
going down or up but like yeah yeah like
the whole idea of like things rising and
falling as possible